pokemon legends arceus looks incredible
with the game's release fast approaching
now is the perfect time to break down
everything that we do know about the
game if you're excited for this game
like i am then be sure to like this
video and sub to the channel because
we're gonna have a whole lot of pokemon
coming your way
there's so much to talk about so let's
dive right into the story pokemon
legends arceus takes place in the
distant past and what we currently know
as sinnoh except in the game it's known
as the hissui region mount coronet
remains dominant on the region's horizon
and this frontier represents a time when
pokemon inhumans did not live in harmony
our character is part of the galaxy team
survey corps and your goal is to
basically go out on different
assignments and expeditions and observe
pokemon for research don't worry you'll
have plenty of opportunities to train
catch and battle pokemon out in the
field as well along the way you'll
encounter different characters such as
wardens which are basically gym leaders
as well as other pokemon some new some
old with distinct new features though
you'll even run into different clans
representing diamond and pearl
respectively some of the pokemon in the
story have been blessed with mysterious
power and are considered noble pokemon
many noble pokemon have been undergoing
a frenzy due to a strange phenomenon
that isn't quite understood as a member
of the survey corps you will be tasked
with finding a solution and will be
called upon to help the frenzied pokemon
out of their current state overall your
goal is the same as many other games in
the franchise to see every pokemon in
the hisoui region and conduct research
to complete the first ever pokedex it is
worth noting that simply catching
pokemon won't get the job done either
you'll have to go deeper and carry out
various tasks to fully complete a
pokedex entry by observing and
researching all the different pokemon we
also have a whole new cast of characters
to encounter throughout legends arceus
making up different groups and factions
to go alongside the new story of course
our protagonist and our counterpart are
usually pokedex partners friends or
rivals your counterpart will be either
akari or rey depending on which
character that you choose the pokemon
professor in this game is professor
laverton who has conducted research on
pokemon and has the ultimate goal of
completing the world's first pokedex
other members of the galaxy team such as
commander kamado and captain celine are
senior members who hold themselves to
high standards and can be strict then
you have the wardens unlike most people
in the hisou region these characters are
potent trainers who have mastered
training pokemon and are best compared
to gym leaders from the modern games in
legends arceus these wardens have the
vital task of taking care of the noble
pokemon the wardens make sure the
pokemon have food and their territories
are protected mai and east khan are two
examples each taking care of a
particular type of pokemon pokemon
legends arceus is also the home to the
two primary conflicting clans the
diamond and pearl clans each with their
own leader adaman and irida the two
clans don clothing that resembles pretty
familiar pokemon for those who have
played the diamond in pearl games each
clan pays homage and respect to the
special pokemon they refer to as lords
and ladies all of which can be
considered noble pokemon some of the
wardens even have clan allegiances too
for example irizu is part of the diamond
clan while leon's loyalty is with pearl
here's a quick fun fact as we go through
the wide castle characters you can see
physical resemblances between certain
characters from legends arceus and those
in diamond and pearl indicating family
lineage commander kamado for example has
a striking resemblance to professor
rowan also akari and rey they look like
diamond and pros lucas and dawn
the hussui region will be incredibly
diverse with different sections of the
map serving as the habitat for various
species of pokemon some only appearing
in particular areas or during certain
times of the day this region aspect
isn't particularly new to pokemon fans
but it's worth noting that the region
seems to be more open than any pokemon
game to date however game freak has
shied from outright claiming that it's a
genuinely open world game like breath of
the wild instead the game seems to have
more of a monster hunter approach you
start at a central hub such as jubilee
village venture out into the wilderness
and battle survey or catch wild pokemon
then you return to the village or you
set up a camp in the region the galaxy
team calls jupiter village its home and
is the main operations base for the
survey security and medical corps
venture out and you'll see distinct
parts of the map such as the obsidian
field lens among numerous other areas
you can see a variety of landscapes and
locations in the trailers released so
far ranging from the sea to quiet
meadows and dense woods all along the
frontier the different pokemon and
legends arceus is what i'm personally
looking forward to the most we have a
sweet variety of starters right off the
bat each from a different pokemon game
cyndaquil from gen 2 oshawa from gen 5
and rowlet from gen 6. it is not an easy
choice all three starters are excellent
companions and trainers especially new
ones they'll learn to fall in love with
them just like we all did with our first
pokemon game when it comes to what
separates legends arceus and makes it
different from other games it is the
different variations and twists on
pokemon that we're used to seeing
turning them into something brand new
let's start with noble pokemon a
mysterious blessing has been granted to
certain pokemon that distinguishes them
from other standard wild pokemon some
noble pokemon are friendly and willing
to work alongside trainers but others
are far more aggressive and they might
attack on sight it's not entirely clear
why but noble pokemon can go into a
dangerous frenzy that demands the survey
core's attention you also have alpha
pokemon the easiest way to tell which
pokemon is alpha is by simply looking at
their eyes all alpha pokemons seem
larger than average with glowing red
eyes and they are super aggressive
they'll attack you or chase you down on
site however the benefit of catching
them is vast successfully catch an alpha
pokemon and they can become valuable
partners on your team and some may even
drop extra rare items historically when
you catch a lot of pokemon you stash
them away in pc boxes ready to swap in
and out of your battle teams at a
pokemon center this time in legends
arceus there is no pc storage system
instead you'll have your pokemon relax
and roam close off pastures within
jubilate village there are some new
hisoui exclusive evolutions to classic
pokemon as well were deer the normal
psychic deer pokemon is an evolution of
stantler while basculesian and cleaver
are evolutions of basculin and scyther
regional variants of pokemon have been a
thing for a few generations now such as
alolan and golerian forms and the hisui
region has its own set of exclusive
forms one recently revealed his sui form
is voltorb sporting a dope wood finish
volturb has different typing being an
electric grass type pokemon now some
other hissui forms include growlithe
braviary and zoroark then we've got the
mythical pokemon of course arceus
darkrai and shaman have all been
confirmed although we don't have any
idea yet on how exactly we'll be
encountering these pokemon at the moment
darkrai isn't in brilliant diamond and
shining pearl as of its launch so
personally it's exciting to see dark
ryan legends arceus
all right lastly let's talk about the
gameplay there is a level of seamless
transitions apparently between
adventuring and battling which has me
pretty excited the core gameplay loop
when searching for pokemon can be broken
down into four steps seek observe weaken
and catch the world is rich and you
can't expect to see every pokemon simply
emerge from the tall grass since you
might have to take things a step further
and search for pokemon hidden in rock
crevices or tucked away in the branches
of a tree you'll also want to observe a
pokemon's behavior before deciding if
you will battle it as mentioned before
particularly with noble pokemon some of
them might be aggressive which means you
will want to be as stealthy as possible
before engaging if you decide to weaken
a pokemon first you will want to chuck a
pokeball containing one of your pokemon
at your target which will seamlessly
trigger a battle the flow of action will
not be like previous games which were
always turn based this time your pokemon
stats and battle style will determine
the flow allowing some pokemon to attack
several times in a row you could also
potentially mix things up by having your
pokemon launch a few attacks and then
aiding or healing them with a battle
item or some medicine all within the
same turn no hms in this game either
from what i can see instead you have a
unique item known as the celestica flute
which will summon certain hisui pokemon
that will let you traverse the region
through land sea or air fly with the
braviary speed through fields with the
word deer or surf the water with a
basket lesion when battling there are
two notable styles agile and strong
these styles will change the way a move
hits with the agile style raising your
pokemon's action speed but reducing the
strength of each hit strong style means
fewer moves in quick succession but a
more substantial impact for each attack
combined with your opponent's stats
versus your party's built this will go a
long way in dictating how battles play
out throughout your adventure once the
pokemon is weakened you'll have to aim
carefully and toss a pokeball or heavy
ball at your target and if the pokemon
doesn't burst out of the ball then it's
a successful catch when it comes to
battling frenzied pokemon simply
weakening your opponent won't cut it
anymore instead you will have to
actually dodge the frenzy pokemon's
attacks and try to soothe it by throwing
bombs these bombs are made up of the
frenzied pokemon's favorite foods and
the best tactic is to combine throwing
the bombs while weakening the frenzied
pokemon the weaker the pokemon gets the
greater the chance your bombs will be
effective throughout the game you will
also encounter trading posts that will
let you trade the pokemon you've caught
with other players there are even
customization options for your character
namely through the clothing shop and
hairdressers besides customizing
cosmetics you can also scrounge for
materials to use in the new crafting
system it seems like a straightforward
system combining particular materials at
any workbench for items that you can use
in the field such as pokeballs there are
general stores and craft works where you
can replenish your supplies and by
crafting recipes expanding the threshold
of items that you can combine they're
supposed to be pokemon home support for
legends arceus but just not at launch
and there are estimates of the service
will be available in late 2022.
man that's a lot to chew on and this
close to launch there is a lot more that
we'll discover soon be sure to stick
with gamespot because we'll have a
review and a lot of good tips and guides
coming your way we even got a fun things
you didn't know about pokemon video live
right now on our channel so check that
out i really want to know what you guys
are most excited about in the comments
below and if you've already seen the
leaks please keep the comments spoiler
free if you got any other questions make
sure to drop them in there too and sound
off until next time
[Music]